hello and welcome to see you playing the
spec tiger who is that tahia white oh ok
ok Kings Indian again I must have played
Ray dozens of games with his age three
stuff and I still haven't gotten to
something that I would call good
knowledge about it would show that
snappy should be three I don't know what
is he doing there 96 interesting so we
delay z5 here for a very long time hmm I
wonder if I can do something this move
into this kind of intriguing maybe I can
prevent if I of him it's a bit strange
but maybe he might have vm he might have
something like that but a thought Bishop
age to e5 I thought c5 would be
interesting something it's a bit of a
gamble if it doesn't work it doesn't
work c5 takes takes their takes them
it's a very strange position I actually
after each takes I could play 92
looks very strange but it's may be
interesting which should be six would
windy exchange also if he allows that
and the current circumstances
hmm Jeff I don't know what I'd like to
do this move wow wow okay okay so what's
the deal here um ok fatigue okay I'll
take and return the piece I mean I will
lose it back anyway and maybe this one
no should be success the materialistic
move but probably not a good move 94 66
yeah anyway I should make a decision and
then see what happens it takes f3 I
think knight takes Bishop b2 b1 and a
half bishop t6 at the end sure black
will probably always have compensation
if i win the exchange and you might have
entirely different moves that I
overlooked this is very possibly much
possible but it takes this oh and that I
didn't expect okay you won and queen dee
5 power
yeah anyway anything else that I can do
here I can just take these two md3 in
this position and route 28 okay I'm I'm
grabbing this let's let's take it so
what now king cakes I will just take the
three like take the money at run the
bishop takes probably be for Bishop
takes us also rupee eight yeah rupee
eight but ok that doesn't threaten that
much since night at six I came what is
he doing here again shocking me with the
move they didn't expect it
yeah Bishop takes I will play before I
guess a five now maybe I just take
everything out take d3i care it as I
still feel attracted to that maybe yes a
five that said certainly a possibility I
outside rookie 50 I should have thought
about that a little bit longer rookie
five was definitely definitely an option
okay I'm 22 here Queen d2 yeah that's a
check I thought the check would be good
Jack isn't that good Quincy three here
or something like that why do I have
something better here and let's do it
threatens made that threatens check mail
I have six is the only move I think and
then I have a a 14 1 is 7 check
so what now g5 probably but then when I
should have some kind of win after c5
now after g5 sorry g5 talking nonsense
eg5 how do I win against that check King
g6 I don't see a checkmate I don't see a
check where my usual problem ok now
where is the bloody mate
I can win a piece or so I'm also happy
but I don't see it Luke GA discovered
maybe g3 here Knight takes King f1 that
threaten screen text III ok IM us under
stove simply I have no time I hope I'm
not screwing this up it would really be
a shame jack is a nice position I don't
see it I really don't see anything for
him Queen takes t3 now as a threat yeah
yeah I'm can I can take the rook but
maybe also night thanks Noah g4 is also
my [ __ ] stinks check ok I can't think
I just take the rook here there's
checkmate on age 7 or not no there's no
major supership there oops um what am I
doing here
I used to type this chick check still
kind of kind of tricky very tricky
actually oops check her to cut them
check don't believe this stuff I don't
believe it I was screwing this up and
now I have no check here unbelievable I
know right I made and getting a chick
made it here check check wow what a joke
why unbelievable yeah okay it was kind
of shaky back in position here but I
don't know it's probably plus a million
I should just take the rope here on
eight and two rooks up here I have a g4
also wins of course Jan I just didn't
see how jigs queen bee three I shouldn't
allow the check that i am twin b3s queen
bee three is probably clear clearly des
trading the Queen right yeah this is
trading the Queen okay I'm just an idiot
totally idea to check check this is this
is still winning with 91 but this is
getting scary and I cannot shake matin
and this is however me
I mean this is plus 9y of course you
always win in a in a normal time control
but yeah here it's already a draw and
this is losing yeah but how am I
supposed to find the draw here this is a
draw j + f5 yeah okay I should just yeah
it's always it's hard to believe that
guy's loses this game it's just g3 is
actually the strongest move check dad
wasn't was a really good well played
game until I'm screwing everything up
here I also tend to play far too
complicated here can I take this
actually no this is this is a bad idea
yeah I can also take the rook act
whatever does no it's no use in
analyzing like just got completely
killed and then I allowed him to check
made me okay well thanks for watching